금은 참 이상한 자산입니다.
누군가에게 금은 장신구이고, 누군가에게는 투자 상품입니다.
그런데 어떤 나라에서는 금이 단순한 자산이 아닙니다.
돈이 무너질 때 마지막으로 붙잡는 피난처이고,
중앙은행이 위기를 버텨내기 위해 꺼내드는 담보이며,
때로는 정권의 시간을 벌어주는 정치적 자산이 되기도 합니다.
오늘 우리가 주목할 이야기는 바로 터키입니다.
국제금 가격은 2026년 1월 고점을 찍은 뒤 잠시 주춤했습니다.
금 가격은 미국 금리, 달러 가치, 중앙은행 매입, 지정학적 리스크 같은 여러 변수로 움직이는데,
세계금위원회는 2016년 3월 금 가격이 하락한 주요 원인 중 하나로 뜻밖의 나라를 지목했습니다.
바로 터키입니다.
여기서 질문이 생깁니다.
터키가 도대체 뭘 했길래 세계 금 가격에 영향을 줬을까요?
금값이 높아서 차익 실현을 한 걸까요?
아니면 더 급한 이유가 있었던 걸까요?
이 이야기를 이해하려면 금 가격 차트만 봐서는 안됩니다.
터키 리라화, 인플레이션, 중앙은행, 에르도안의 정치 일정, 그리고 중국의 금매입까지 같이 봐야 합니다.
먼저 리라화부터 보겠습니다.
터키 리라화는 계속 약해지고 있습니다.
최근 1년만 봐도 원화보다 훨씬 약한 모습을 보이고 있고, 10년 흐름으로 보면 더 분명합니다.
리라화는 장기적으로 계속 가치가 떨어지고 있는 화폐입니다.
화폐가치가 하락한 가장 큰 이유는 인플레이션 때문이겠죠.
터키의 물가 흐름은 우리가 익숙한 수준과 다릅니다.
중요한 점은 연간 물가가 아니라 월간 물가입니다.
2016년 4월에도 터키 소비자 물가는 전월 대비 4.18% 올랐습니다.
한 달에 물가가 4% 넘게 오른다는 뜻입니다.
한국에서 물가가 한 달에 4% 오른다고 생각해 보시면 됩니다.
지난달 만 원이었던 물건이 이번 달에는 만 4백 원이 되고, 그 다음 달에는 다시 또 오릅니다.
이 흐름이 이어지면 단순 계산으로 1년이면 물가가 50% 가까이 오를 수 있습니다.
그러면 리라화로 월급을 받고, 리라화로 예금을 들고 있고, 리라화로 자산을 보유하고 있는 사람들은 어떻게 될까요?
통장 잔고는 그대로인 것 같지만 실제 구매력은 계속 줄어들겠죠.
그래서 터키 사람들은 리라화 대신 금, 달러, 비트코인 같은 자산으로 이동하려고 합니다.
원래 물가를 잡으려면 금리를 올리는 것이 일반적인 처방입니다.
그런데 터키는 반대로 움직이고 있습니다.
2014년 말 47.5%였던 기준금리를
2016년 4월에는 37%까지 낮췄습니다.
물가가 높은데 금리를 내린 겁니다.
왜 이런 일이 벌어질까요?
여기서부터는 경제 작동 원리만 보면 안 되고 정치를 같이 봐야 합니다.
에르도완 대통령은 2023년 재선에 성공했습니다.
원칙대로라면 2028년에는 대통령직에서 내려와야 합니다.
터키는 대통령 3년임이 제한되어 있기 때문이죠.
그런데 예외가 있습니다.
대통령이 두 번째 임기 중일 때 의회가 조기 선거를 결의하면
현직 대통령이 한 번 더 출마할 수 있습니다.
즉 2028년 대선을 2027년으로 앞당기면 에르도완은 다시 출마할 수 있고
승리하면 2033년까지 집권할 수 있습니다.
이제 터키의 금 이야기는 단순한 중앙은행 자산운용이 아니라
에르도완의 정치 일정과도 연결되는 겁니다.
물론 조기 선거를 하려면 조건이 필요하겠죠.
터키의 의회는 600석이고 조기 선거에는 60% 즉 360명의 동의가 필요합니다.
현재 에르도완의 연립정당은
318석을 가지고 있습니다.
360석까지는 42석이 부족하죠.
여기에 쿠르드계 정당 DEM당이 변수로 등장합니다.
DEM당은 57석을 가지고 있습니다.
에르도완 연립정당 318석에 DEM당 57석을 더하면 375석입니다.
조기 선거를 열 수 있는 숫자를 넘기게 되죠.
원래 이 둘의 관계는 좋지 않았습니다.
에르도완은 DEM당을 쿠르드 저항세력 PKK의 하구조직으로 보며 압박했고
정당 해산까지 시도했던 적이 있죠.
하지만 2023년 선거 이후 DEM당이 캐스팅보트를 쥘 수 있는 위치가 되자
관계 개선 움직임이 나타납니다.
PKK 창설자 외질란 문제, 쿠르드족 자치확대 같은 카드가 계속 거름대는 이유도 여기에 있는 겁니다.
야당인 CHP도 조기 선거를 무조건 피하려는 분위기는 아닙니다.
오히려 2017년 조기 선거 가능성을 높게 보고 81개 도시에 18만6천명의 선거 참관인을 지정하며 조직동원에 나섰습니다.
왜냐하면
현재 AKP와 CHP 지지율이 32%와 31.7%로 거의 붙어있기 때문입니다.
물론 상황은 복잡합니다.
CHP의 유력 대선 주자였던 이스탄불 시장 이마무울루는 2025년에 구속되어 재판 중입니다.
이마무울루 외에도 수감된 CHP 소속 시장이 14명에 달하고 200명 이상의 당직자가 구속되거나 조사를 받고 있습니다.
이런 상황에서 조기 선거가 열리면 야당은 임기 연장을 위한 선거라는 프레임을 만들 수 있습니다.
그러니까 에르도안에게 조기 선거는 기회이지만 동시에 위험입니다.
그래서 결국 중요한 것은 경제겠죠.
물가가 계속 오르고 리라화가 무너지면 선거는 어려워집니다.
리라와 가치를 방어하는 쪽에 가깝습니다.
터키 중앙은행은 2016년 리라와 절하폭을
5% 수준으로 통제하려고 하고 있습니다.
리라와 가치를 최대한 유지해서
인플레이션을 눌러보겠다는 계산입니다.
그런데 리라와를 방어하려면 달러가 필요합니다.
리라와가 흔들릴 때 시장에 달러를 공급하고
외환시장의 불안을 눌러야 하기 때문입니다.
문제는 그 달러를 어디서 마련하느냐겠죠.
여기서 터키 중앙은행에 금이 등장하는 겁니다.
터키 중앙은행은 2015년 9월 641톤이던 금 보위량을
2016년 4월 535톤까지 줄였습니다.
약 106톤, 금액으로는 대략 170억 달러 규모입니다.
특히 이 중 58톤이 2016년 3월에 줄었습니다.
그래서 세계금위원회가 3월 금값 하락의 원인 중
하나로 터키를 지목한 겁니다.
하지만 여기서 중요한 반전이 있습니다.
터키가 이 금을 전부 시장에 내답한 것은 아닙니다.
감소한 106톤 중 약 80톤은
금달러 수압으로 처리된 것으로 알려져 있습니다.
금달러 수압은 금을 담보로 맡기고
달러를 빌리는 구조입니다.
나중에 달러를 갚으면 금을 다시 돌려받을 수 있습니다.
그러니까 터키가 금이 싫어져서 팔아버린 것이 아닙니다.
지금 당장 필요한 달러를 마련하기 위해서
가장 믿을 수 있는 자산인 금을 담보로 활용한 겁니다.
터키에게 지금 필요한 것은 금 그 자체가 아니라
리라화를 방어할 달러입니다.
정확히는 선거 전까지 경제를 흔들리지 않게 붙잡아둘 시간이 필요한 겁니다.
정확히는 선거 전까지 경제 흔들리지 않게 붙잡아둘 시간이 필요한 겁니다.
그런데 터키 금 시장에서 진짜 수요자는 정부보다 민간입니다.
인플레이션이 심하고 리라화 가치가 계속 떨어지면
사람들은 자연스럽게 리라화를 피하게 됩니다.
터키 민간이 보유한 금은 5천억 달러 이상으로 추선되고
전 세계 금 수요의 17%를 터키인들이 차지한다는 이야기도 나옵니다.
터키 국민에게 금은 투자 상품이면서 동시에 생존형 통화입니다.
그러자 터키 정부는 민간의 금 수요를 막으려 했습니다.
2023년 8월 가공되지 않는 금 수입을 월 12톤으로 제한하는 쿼터 제도를 시행했습니다.
국민들이 금을 사기 위해 달러를 계속 쓰면 외화가 빠져나가고
리라화 약세와 인플레이션이 다시 심해지기 때문입니다.
실제로 이 조치 이후 연간 300톤 수준이던 금 수입은
2024년 126톤 수준으로 떨어졌습니다.
겉으로는 정책이 효과를 낸 것처럼 보입니다.
하지만 시장은 어떻게든 우회로를 찾게 됩니다.
미가공 금 수입이 막히자 소비재로 분류되는
귀금속 형태로 금을 들여오기 시작한 겁니다.
그 결과 쿼터제가 시행된 2013년 8월 16억 달러 수준이던 귀금속 금 수입은
2014년 11월 64억 달러를 넘어섰습니다.
수입은 제한되던데 수요는 줄지 않자
터키 안에서는 24K 순금 가격이 국제시세보다 비싸게 거래되는 프리미엄도 생겼습니다.
터키의 금 가격에는 단순한 금값이 아니라
리라화에 대한 불신이 얹혀 있는 겁니다.
그렇다면 터키가 내놓은 금은 어디로 갈까요?
여기서 중국이 등장합니다.
터키가 내놓은 금은 주로 중국이 확보하고 있는 것으로 보입니다.
중국은 17개월 연속 금을 사들이고 있고
중국 중앙은행의 금 보유량은 2,312톤까지 늘어났습니다.
터키는 리라화를 방어하기 위해 금을 줄이고
중국은 달러 중심 금융질서에서 거리를 두기 위해 금을 늘리고 있습니다.
같은 금이지만 터키에게는 위기를 버티기 위한 담보이고
중국에게는 장기전략 자산입니다.
그래서 오늘 이야기는 금값이 오른다 내린다를 말하려는 이야기가 아닙니다.
정치와 경제를 함께 엮어서 지금 터키가 왜 금을 줄이고 있는지
그리고 그 금이 국제금 수급 속에서 어떻게 움직이고 있는지를 정리해 본 겁니다.
터키 정부는 금을 담보로 달러를 끌어와 리라화를 방어하려고 하고 있습니다.
반대로 터키 국민들은 리라화를 믿지 못해 금으로 피신하고 있습니다.
그리고 그 반대편에서는 중국이 조용히 금을 사들이고 있습니다.
같은 금이지만
누군가에게는 위기를 버티기 위한 담보이고
누군가에게는 생존을 위한 피난처이며
누군가에게는 달러 질서에 대비하는 전략 자산입니다.
결국 금은 가격만 보는 자산이 아닙니다.
금은 한 나라의 통화불안, 정치 일정, 중앙은행의 선택
그리고 국제 자금 흐름이 겹쳐지는 지점에 있습니다.
정치에 과하게 몰입하는 것이 투자 수익률에 늘 도움이 되는 것은 아닙니다.
하지만 정치를 아예 모르는 것도 위험할 수 있습니다.
시장을 움직이는 주요 변수 하나를 보지 못하게 되겠고
터키의 금을 보면 그 점이 분명해집니다.
금값 자체보다 중요한 것은 그 금을 누가 왜 팔고
누가 왜 사들이고 있는가입니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.